thank you very much and now ladies and
gentlemen I think we owe a debt of
gratitude to ABC for putting aside their
television ratings war for one night and
devote this solely to the art of motion
pictures as Mork from ork was telling me
backstage and he's about to introduce
the first honorary warden
here's America's newest comedy sensation
a young man who was about to star as
Popeye in his very first movie ladies
and gentlemen
Robin Williams
thank you good evening in for those you
were the buzz on
ever since the beginning of time
producers and directors have been
searching for a method of presenting
entertainment without the need for
actors the dream finally came - with the
discovery of animation a character an
animated film would not only do what
they artist commands him to do he'll
never rewrite dialogue he'll never ask
for motivation you never go through
puberty and best of all he'll never have
an agent tonight the Board of Governors
of the Academy bestows an honorary award
one of the most respected and beloved
producers of animation for 60 years he's
been creating delightful characters for
both adults and children alike and been
the pleasure of many generations in over
80 countries all around the world his
name is Walter Lantz
on behalf of the Academy I'm happy to
give you this award for doing strange
and wonderful things with a laughing
bird thank you very much
would you like to meet woody we may he's
not at Michael's pub he's here tonight
yes he's here wonderful yeah I have one
question I like to ask is it true what
the National Enquirer said about he and
Betty Boop's you've been asking yourself
alright Robin this is woody woody meet
Ronnie whoa what's happening my mane was
old her listen you're looking good after
40 years hey I've got a dynamite deal on
some uncut redwood all I have to do is
knock twice and ask for smokey he likes
me yes that's his way of saying he's
happy to meet you I also like to say
thanks to this man Walter Lantz who's
been drawing me and a very nice paycheck
too for over 38 years I'm one bird in
his hand that's worth a lot more than
two in the bush not wood
congratulations boss and a Gracie -
who's been putting words in my mouth all
these years you're both tap-tap-tap in
my book
I'd like to thank the Board of Governors
of the Academy for this great honor I
really appreciate the Oscar not only for
my contribution to the art of animation
but also as a tribute to the entire
cartoon industry and to Universal
Pictures with whom I've been associated
for 50 years thank you
ladies and gentlemen Danny Thomas is
about to come out here and explain the
voting procedures for the Academy Awards
for you people watching at home this
might be a good time to go into the
kitchen and make some more dip
ah Danny just paid George Burns a big
compliment backstage he said George I
saw you and Oh God and you really
captured me George had his cigar as
usual and exhaled a big puff of white
smoke and Danny headed for Rome ladies
and gentlemen we welcome mr. Danny
Thomas
thank you very much young ladies and
gentlemen each year the Academy chooses
a star to make him an unknown and
tonight I'm the one I'm about to read
you your rights
we have to first advise you of all the
voting procedures which are carried out
by the active members of the Academy of
all the categories there's only one in
which all members may nominate and that
is the outstanding picture of the year
the others are decided by the members of
the various individual branches however
there are three categories that are
determined in an entirely different
manner in the case of the documentaries
the short subjects and the foreign films
only members who attend all the Academy
screenings of these films cast a vote
then when all the nominations are
complete the entire membership may vote
on all the categories in secret of
course and the ballots are collected by
the Academy's venerable body of
independent accountants Price Waterhouse
& Company the final results are known
only to two men the exceedingly reticent
mr. Frank Johnson who along with his
assistant John Blair is here with the
envelopes which mean so much to so few
John I thank you very much and may the
Lord bless you
but Danny was trying to say is the
person who gets the most votes wins